today our test driver Christophe Bauer
is taking an unusual Brazilian
best-seller for a spin VW brasilia built
in 1980 in the 50s Brazil became one of
VW's most important markets back then
the German company only offered two
models the Beetle and the classic van
even so its head Heinrich Norville
gained access to global markets helping
turned Volkswagen into the European car
maker with the highest turnover
Christoph relates the history of VW in
Brazil in 1953 it opened its first
foreign plant in Brazil
at first they built a beetle there which
would remain the most popular car in
Brazil for decades so popular even that
it got its own nickname for Scott the
classic VW bus also took South America
by storm by the late 1960s would of
lightning then head of VW w zu and
leader chairman of the company began
initiating new tailored models Christoph
explains of course the fundamental
platform for it all was the good old
beetle I'm spending naturalist acutal
taking
it's platform frame and separate body
technology that was both simple and
robust made the practically
indestructible VW the perfect starting
point for developing new models although
the way the beetle was constructed was
already outdated by the 1970s the
underlying concept would remain vibrant
for years to come
[Music]
the ants for sure very clear demands
will be made on the new Brazilian VW
Christophe explains it would have to be
even more practical more efficient and
more spacious than the beetle it said
that after 40 different prototypes the
engineers put together in shimira
combining all the best features the 1600
CC motor is from the beetle the four
segments from the Karmann Ghia and then
mounted a station wagon style body from
the VW type 3 on top the series was
launched in 1973 says Christoph and was
named after the country's capital
Brasilia this one is in specially good
shape he thinks I could just left the
factory
Lehman's it that he meant as completed
interviewer induce it to get fooled
again packing already at first the VW
Brasilia was also available with five
doors for tax purposes the fastback
model was initially marketed as a small
delivery van bit by bit the new station
wagon grew popularity across the
continent staff notices that the
combined rear engine and drive make the
Brasilia fairly unstable at high speeds
but considering it wasn't easy to reach
the cars top speed of 138 kilometers an
hour on Brazil's notorious highways
that's no big deal
Marsha Pyong Castelli was the one who
came up with the brasília somewhat
peculiar designed he apparently was
inspired by variants of Wolfsburg x'
type three and four station wagon models
appropriately called variant these two
had a modern and spacious two box frame
that was himself supporting but mounted
just like the beetle to save it from the
ravages of time the previous owner
wrapped the interior and plastic not
very attractive but effective
[Music]
so I'm combi design the general idea
behind the fastback Christophe thinks is
to provide more cargo space and make
loading easier but with a Brasilia
that's not really the case the loading
sill is extremely high and there's
hardly any space in the trunk that's
because the 54 horsepower air-cooled
four-cylinder box engine with 1.6 liters
displacement is right below of course
and good old beetle style it's not flat
but upright with huge fans and that
takes up room
the VW Brasilia is certainly not a
perfect car owners often complained it
had serious rust issues legend has it
that even light collisions could cause
rusted through floor panels to drop out
taking passengers with them
[Music]
despite these defects Christophe says
roughly a million VW brasilia's were
manufactured and sold in Brazil over ten
years they also spread to Mexico and
Nigeria where the car was christened the
Eagle ax and even if the Brasilia was
always something of a ruling anachronism
buyers could even get it with a 1.3
ethanol motor towards the end of its
production lines come on it's a toy
ethanol is a commonplace alternative to
gasoline in Brazil today most Brazilian
vehicles have so-called
total flex engines that can handle any
mixture the two fuels regardless of
ratio
[Music]
in Europe the VW brasilia has remained a
rarity only a few of them can be found
in Portugal or on the Canary Islands fre
but in many ways Krista thinks the VW
Brasilia can be considered the final
stage of evolution of the beetle concept
from the 1930s in that sense he says
it's a milestone in car history but its
predecessor outlived it while the VW
Brasilia was discontinued in 1982 the
beetle continued to be manufactured in
Brazil until 1996 it was succeeded by
the South American take on the Gulf
which remains the most widely sold car
on the continent to this day
[Music]
you